and q music and you need them
happy founders day rutherford falls
you know our fair town wasn't always
going to be called rutherford falls
that's right old lawrence changed his
mind six times at one point he was dead
set on naming it after his brother horus
you say that out loud it sounds like
whoresville
[Laughter]
needless to say they moved on from that
one pretty quick i guess what i'm trying
to say
is changing one's mind is distinctly
rutherfordian
and that's why i've changed my mind and
i've come to the conclusion
that it's the right thing to do to move
big larry yeah nope it's okay don't
freak out don't freak
out no it's actually kind of exciting
because the new location is
pretty cool good for you nathan can we
focus on the problems that are actually
important
well big larry's important more
important than the opioid crisis
yeah apples and oranges carla we should
refurbish him
he looks old and sad okay folks this is
not a q a
uh all right bunny let's wrap it up
support refurbishing not resculpting
screw that we should get a new statue
that thing's like a billion years old
what about like jenna marbles
or my dog she's got like 2 000 followers
on instagram
people the moving of big larry is on the
table
not replacing him are you kidding me
he's the heart and soul of this town
i have something to say oh no bonnie in
1951
a woman named juanita cordova went into
labor on her way to albany we've had
this argument bonnie she couldn't wait
and gave birth to a daughter in
rutherford falls
that little girl would become tv
superstar
linda carter wonder woman was born in
our town
okay yes a woman named linda carter was
born in our town there is absolutely no
evidence that it was the linda carter
who went on to tv stardom we are not
building a statue
of wonder woman in our town deirdre back
me up
i respect the voices of my constituents
let's chase his momentum in a hundred
years who's going to care about big
larry i don't care about
shut up shut your stupid pie holes just
laugh
yeah cause you don't get it you're not
getting it okay a bunch of years ago
lawrence rutherford
wrote and signed a legally binding
agreement with the minnesota
that's why this town exists that's why
all of you exist okay lawrence
rutherford
is our forefather he's our adam and eve
our tigris and euphrates
and that statue which sits on my
family's land
commemorates all that he gave us and if
you don't get that well
you're just an ungrateful boob you know
what i'll change my mind again
big larry's gonna stay right where he is
nope not gonna budge
not only that but i'm gonna double down
on my efforts to make sure each and
every one of you understands exactly how
important he is and why it's so
important
that he's there and if you disagree you
can burn in hell
yeah just burn right up you gotta go get
your boy
okay no but i'm not done telling these
people why they're wrong and stupid
okay all right okay but there's
you're gonna hear more about this
[Music]
you